so you lived a secret life as a high-end
thief
you two bring us this crown and no one
gets hurt
if we steal this you leave my family
alone
now i have to ask you guys if you were
both able to steal one item in the world
what would it be and why i would say
the declaration of independence like
nick cage and national treasure
because i know how to do it now i sort
of have a template of how
how you can get that done it's still
dangerous
and i could still not get it done but i
have sort of a road map of
how it can get done i'd probably steal
tom hardy
yeah that was a great answer i mean
that's more like kidnapping but whatever
why would somebody take your parents
look this is mom's necklace
she never takes us off ever she's trying
to tell us something
what was it like prepping for those
fighting scenes because you
some ass girl like thank you it was fun
it was it's so much fun to do scenes
like that you really
get into it and you feel pretty cool
until you look at playback and you're
like
doesn't look as cool as it feels because
you see all the stun people around you
just
nailing it you know what i mean they
come prepared they have this thing
called the theragun which
is awesome it's like a massage gun that
just
gets in there because once you pass 40
and you're doing those things it just
feels a little different than when you
did it when you were in your 30s
oh no that i don't think that came from
us
believe it or not we'll leave it out did
either of you have any memorable
sleepovers growing up with friends oh my
god can i tell you about one that was
a sleepover at a campsite in
grew up in toronto canada and so we went
up to
um georgian bay which is one of the
beautiful lakes there and
as you may may not know there's a lot of
bears and so we were sleeping in a tent
and i was there with my friend and her
mom and
woke up in the middle of the night to a
bare head
and pot in the tent because we hadn't
put the food outside
that was the most memorable i peed my
pants i really did
i peed myself i was so scared i can't
talk
about a similar thing i went camping
and uh peed my pants on a sleepover
but there was no bear how old were you
24.